hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in her essay
trying out one's new sword mary Midgley
coins a term moral isolationism that she
uses to describe a certain type of
relativistic position in ethics and
she's primarily focused on a kind of
cultural relativism but this could be
applied much more broadly to other
varieties of ethical relativism for
example those that might have to do with
race class gender within a society or to
saying you can't understand me and judge
me because you don't come from the same
background or have the same experiences
as I do and we'll talk about that and
those implications a bit later for right
now let's stick with what she's talking
about so what is what she's calling
moral isolationism
it's a standpoint ethical perspective on
the possibility of having ethical
perspectives about those who are
different those who are other those who
belong to another culture and she says
that in our own day we're hearing about
other people's cultures and customs and
activities we see changes in our
lifetime which would have astonished our
parents and I'm going to discuss one
very short way of dealing with this
difficulty a drastic way
which many people now theoretically
favor and this is what she's calling
moral isolationism and she tells us
about some of its key features so what
are these she says it consists in simply
denying we can ever understand any
culture except our own well enough to
make judgments about it so we can't
praise condemn justify explain any other
cultures we can only understand our own
culture we can only understand the
culture that we either were born into or
were adopted into and we're raised
within or perhaps even had imposed upon
us if we lost the culture that we
originated from in the first place and
we're sort of brainwashed into that we
get one and that's it so whatever it is
that you're working with that's your one
culture it's impossible from this point
of view to be the cultural equivalent of
bilingual you cannot straddle multiple
cultures you wouldn't be able to do for
example what they call code-switching in
language using the language of one
culture as opposed to another culture or
rather subculture that would be ruled
out as a possibility because you can
only understand one so we can only
understand our own culture why because
as she puts it societies or something
like hermetically sealed off units with
with each with its own system of thought
it has its own material implements which
we can see at museums or in other places
like National Geographic you know or
whatever other things that you're
getting popular anthropology in and each
one of them is radically different from
the other they may borrow things from
each other but the same thing within a
different culture has a totally
different meaning that we can't possibly
fathom every single culture is its own
world unto itself
a third very important part of this as
she says is wonderful metaphor
that moral judgment is a kind of coinage
valid only in its country of origin so
moral judgment would be saying things
are good or bad right or wrong
better or worse desirable undesirable
the sorts of things that we do in
praising blaming criticizing justifying
suggesting all of that would be possible
only from within the standpoint of one's
own culture so if this is really the
case that implies that unless we have
some radical continuity between say us
and ancient Athens we can't even
understand the moral perspective of
Socrates or the moral perspective of the
ancient Israelites in the Bible or the
moral perspective of Rome let alone the
moral perspective of 16th century China
all of those are sealed off containers
any moral judgments that were made are
only valid within those systems and so
along with this goes the implication
that we since we cannot understand we
can't make judgments about and we can't
even morally reason about other cultures
their practices their works their
justifications their social structures
none of that is things that we could
understand and then judge and then
reason about we can't say whether
they're better or worse we can't compare
them with each other they simply are
what they are for the people who are
living with them and for everybody else
it's a matter of hands off now that's a
very strong relativist position it's not
just saying that different people have
different moral codes it's saying we
literally cannot make sense of the moral
code of a different culture so we cannot
evaluate it in any way whatsoever or use
it as a point of comparison and contrast
either with their own culture or with
other cultures why might a person take a
position
like that so she brings up three main
things one is that within the culture
that we inhabit late modern Western
culture she's writing from a British
standpoint but this could equally apply
to Americans or pretty much anybody in
the first world we tend to value respect
and tolerance for other cultures that is
when we're not engaging saying cultural
appropriation or making fun of them at
racist ways or doing things like that
but there are many of us who do think
that it's important to respect other
cultures to show tolerance you know you
see somebody doing something that looks
a little bit unusual that that you can
just say well they're they're from a
different place what they're doing has a
different meaning to them I'll give you
a great example at a very very fancy
dinner one of the guests of honor who is
from the American West and grew up on
ranches took the fancy dinner napkin and
blew her nose in it to the astonished
and in some cases disgusted stares of
all the onlookers well at least some of
the onlookers because some of us were
like well you know that's what napkins
are used for in other places that would
be showing a kind of Tolerance or a
respect for that culture and instead
quite a few of the other people took
offense to that and thought that it was
very wrong to do the napkins all get
washed in the same washing machine as
everything else
another thing that she talks about is
concerns about the the opposite about
people despising other cultures saying
terrible things about them look at those
barbarians look at those dirty savages
look at those people over there who do
this thing you know
or it could be joking about them it
could be all sorts of things caricatures
oppressing other cultures steamroller to
use her her term other cultures maybe
the idea is that if we adopt this moral
isolationism we don't try to change
everybody to make them like us which in
fact was something that did a
her prime example of that is the
indoctrination of many people from
different Native American tribes for
generations here in the United States
very often in church run schools they
were going to make good Westerners good
Americans out of these these Native
Americans or First Peoples and in effect
they they managed to you know
deracinated them their own culture
produce all sorts of you know bad
emotional effects and complexes and
didn't give them what they really needed
to to succeed in can in the white
culture of the time where they probably
wouldn't have succeeded anyway so maybe
you know if we're tuned to those sorts
of problems we might adopt something
like moral isolationism let people live
over here and live the way that they
want you don't try to indoctrinate them
don't try to remove their culture don't
try to destroy it one of the reasons why
Midgley at the end talks about this
becoming sort of a paradigm is because
we look at the fruits of anthropology as
if they are showing us human nature as
such so she tells us that the universal
predicament of culture which is that
cultures borrow from each other all the
time has been obscured by the fact that
anthropologists used to concentrate
largely on very small and remote
cultures which didn't seem to have this
problem of cultural borrowing these tiny
societies which had often forgotten
their own history made neat
self-contained subjects for study and
she goes on and says no doubt it was
valuable to emphasize the remoteness
their strangeness their independence of
our cultural tradition this emphasis was
I think the root of moral isolationism
and so that gives you an idea of why
somebody might adopt this sort of
standpoint now there are some important
consequences to adopting this standpoint
there there's two of them that she
highlights in general in addition to
pointing out a lot of different problems
that come up as well so one is that as I
pointed out
the moral isolationism as she says has a
general ban on moral reasoning it rules
it out across the board except within
your own framework except within your
own culture now what do we mean by moral
reasoning she says here's just an
example the power of moral judgment is
not a luxury not a perverse indulgence
of the self-righteous it is a necessity
when we judge something to be bad or
good better or worse than something else
we are taking it as an example to aim
that or avoid without opinions of this
sort we would have no framework of
comparison for our own policy
we could form no judgments on our own
actions and she talks a little bit about
Homo sapiens and our brains and how this
is actually part of our very nature
making moral judgments
so moral isolationism would rule out
most moral judgments that we would make
insofar as they involve any sort of
reference to anything outside of our own
culture that would be a significant
problem the other thing that she points
out is logically this sort of position
should in fact lead to what she calls
moral skepticism which would mean that
we would engage in no action at all
because we wouldn't be able to judge it
one way or another as good or bad we
wouldn't be able to carry out practical
reasoning and we wouldn't have an
interest in other cultures or perhaps
even in much of our own and this leads
us to a very important point if you
think about a culture if we talk about
something like the West is the West
really a culture or is it an incredibly
complex network of overlapping cultures
some of which have more dominance than
others how do we treat things like this
within our own society do we say it
matters what race one is classified as
within the the country that one lives in
because of course we know that race as a
socially constructed matter and not
merely as genetic correlates to those
social constructs is very arbitrary
changes from place to place culture to
culture designation to designation
generation to generation if we adopt a
sort of standpoint that says because I'm
not of that race
I can't possibly judge what goes on in
that community I can't even understand
it and they you know may tell me that or
other people on the side and I said who
are you to judge or anything like that
then we're adopting a position of moral
isolationism when we say listen you
can't possibly know what I'm going
through because I have a different
sexual orientation than you I'm a
different gender I come from a different
part of the country you know you're from
the coast I'm from flyover country I'm
from a rural area you're from an urban
area well I grew up in the suburbs you
know I moved around a lot on different
military bases when we say that we can't
understand and therefore can't engage in
any moral reasoning or judgment about
the actions the beliefs the statements
of others because they belong to a
different group were in effect going
into something like Midgley's moral
isolationism that she's pointing out the
problems with here so her conception of
moral isolationism doesn't just apply to
cultural relativism it can apply to
ethical relativism much more broadly
anytime that we have some sort of
determining quality or group or
characteristic that is supposed to act
as a ban on understanding altogether so
that is what Midgley means by moral
isolationism and that is its connection
with relativism
you